of course that was a message from harry
dunn's mother uh to the foreign
secretary we can now hear directly from
uh dominic raab who joins us from
central london thank you very much for
being on the program today
um so difficult uh listening to
charlotte charles there and just seeing
the impact that her son's death has had
on her and her family you're going to be
meeting uh mike pompeo
next week the u.s secretary of state
they're desperate for this to be your
number one priority when you meet him
will it be
well thank you so finn listening to
charlotte
there it's heartbreaking i understand
how
agonizing it's been i understand how
exhausted they are with this
we're on the family side we've made that
clear all along
there's a denial of justice here there
is an extradition request that's
outstanding
uh and we have called on ann serkulis to
return and to
our american partners to facilitate that
we've done that consistently throughout
we've also done other things to try and
ameliorate the situation they won't give
solace they won't give
harry back to the family and we know
that but they do want
uh and securities to return i raised it
with mike pompeo this week of course
we will discuss it when we see them
they've been adamant
throughout that they will not return her
but we will our position remains the
same we're on the side of the family
and she should return i can also just
i think it's worth saying one of the
things we wanted to make sure and the
undertaking that i made both to
parliament as well as to
charlotte and the rest of the family is
to make sure this could never happen
again and we
have negotiated very carefully with the
americans
to change the arrangements the exchange
of letters that will apply
um to the crouton base and the way that
vienna conventional diplomatic relations
will apply
and we're very close to a conclusion on
that and i appreciate that's not the
same thing as ann secular's coming home
it won't bring harry back but it does
allow us
if we can get that over the line to be
able to say that such a situation could
never happen again so
we've been working very hard on all of
those fronts but ultimately ultimately
we can call on the u.s do the right
thing um
and we hope that they will but i think
i'm
also realistic given the consistent
position that they've taken
that they're not going to allow and
secularists she could of course
of her own volition say i i i can feel
the pain that family i will come home
we call on her to make that decision as
well because it sounds a little bit
listen to you that you're effectively
saying there's nothing more you can do
specifically to bring and secures home
because the us have
effectively ignored that extradition
request
and just listening to rad seeger that's
exactly what he doesn't want to hear
because he says that what he wants to
hear is a clear plan
as to what you will do if the u.s
continues to ignore the extradition
request which they have been doing so
far
it sounds a little bit like you're not
going to do anything
no it's not true at all from what i've
just said sophie
one of the things we want to do is make
sure it could never happen again in
relation to
talking specifically about anderson i'm
talking specifically
about the coolest in bringing her back
to faith justice in the uk
yes but i'm also talking about the wider
commitments that we've made in relation
to this case and i think it
should be viewed in context in relation
to ann sekulos
of course we've uh cleared the obstacles
so that
uh the law enforcement the police and
home office can
uh pursue uh charges which is what they
did
that's obviously an independent process
and
there is an extradition uh request that
is outstanding we've consistently raised
this with the u.s
but there's no measures that we could uh
i think credibly realistically
take which is somehow going to force uh
the
the us or indeed answer coolest to
comply with this and
i want to be realistic because i don't
want to raise expectations uh that are
going to be dashed but we have at every
level
i raised this i've raised it uh we've
raised it in washington the prime
minister's raised it
with president trump and we will
continue to make clear we're on the side
of the family here
we think that she should return she must
return home so that justice can be done
and we're doing all the other things
that are within our gift are within our
control
to make sure that this terrible tragedy
and the denial of justice that we've
seen
can't happen again okay uh thank you for
coming on and responding to those very
powerful points
the family made although i'm not sure
how optimistic they will be that ansa
coolest is going to return
to the united kingdom um lots more to
cover
with you um starting with russia because
this week hackers who the uk
believes were almost certainly part of
russian intelligence
services targeted our covered vaccine
programmes
do you believe any information was
stolen
well we've set out and the uh the uk's
um national center for cyber security
set out
the details of this uh we're clear and
by the way it's not just the uk but
we've worked with our
us and canadian counterparts
to set this out so we're absolutely
confident that the russian intelligence
agencies
were uh engaged in a cyber attack on
research and development
uh efforts and organizations in this
country and internationally
uh with a view either to sabotage or to
profit from the r d that was taking
place
and i think the point is first of all
we've seen this as part of a wide assist
systematic approach to cyber taken by
russia and at the time that the world is
coming together
to try and tackle covert 19 particularly
come up with a global solution
for a vaccine i think it's outrageous
and reprehensible
that the russian government is engaged
in this activity
and so what we're doing with our allies
is making sure people know making sure
the organizations know so that they can
better defend them against it but also
just calling russia out and we will do
this now you'll see
uh us holding rush to account and making
sure that the world knows
uh the nature of the reprehensible
behavior that they're engaged in
just as i actually as a leading member
of the international community a
permanent member of the security council
russia should be engaged in that
collaborative international effort
now this has been denied by the russian
ambassador he said i don't believe in
this story at all there is no sense in
it
he's also denied claims this week that
russia interfered
in the uk election we do not interfere
at all
in elections according to the russia
ambassador
is he lying well
first of all there is a distinction
between the cyber attack on the
um uh vaccine uh research
where we have attributed that to the
russian intelligence
agencies along with the us and canada
and
what we've also made clear separately
and it is different is that there was
we're confident that there was russian
actors
uh who were engaged in cyber
efforts to disseminate online efforts to
disseminate and spread
leaked and illegally obtained details
from the u.s
uk uh free trade negotiations but we
haven't yet attributed that
uh any more specifically and that's
because there is an ongoing criminal
investigation underway as for what the
russian ambassador said
look of course he will come on and deny
the attack
uh on the research and development in
relation to vaccines
russia always does this when it's
behaved in such an egregious way they
denied responsibility for the salisbury
attack
in 2018 and we are calling them out and
it's important as with salisbury as with
their cyber
attacks and the other nefarious behavior
russia engages in
we are going to hold them to account and
call them out but look
i'm not surprised in the least that uh
the russian ambassadors wheeled out to
tonight
okay another major issue of course is
our relationship with
china uh the government of course has
taken the decision
to uh change its decision on allowing
huawei access to the uk's 5g network
there are also huge concerns over
china's actions in
hong kong over its actions and treatment
of the wigan muslims over its
transparency on coronavirus
on this show last sunday uh sir richard
dila the former head of mi6 called for a
reset of the whole of our relationship
with china
do we need to have a reset with our
relationship with china
well i think we need to be very careful
in our dealings
look on the one hand we want a positive
relationship with china
there are all sorts of areas and scope
for cooperation not just on investment
and trade and things like that but also
on
climate change which is going to be
really important we're going to shift
the dial on climate change we need to
be able to work with china equally
with uh various uh efforts and again
cyber attacks um the resilience of our
vital interests
like uh 5g and when it comes to signing
up for our values as we've done very
clearly on hong kong
with our offer to those eligible for bno
status
we will always make clear our position
on those key interests and on our key
values to china
and that's the calibrated approach that
we'll take we've said there won't be
business as usual after the covert 19
and we're working with our international
partners to get
a proper independent review of what
happened but we also want to make sure
we're not slipping into some
uh outdated uh dogmatic
uh approach with china um we're we're
going to follow the uk national interest
and we're going to work with our
partners
try and work with china on the things
where we can really accentuate the
positive
but be very clear-sighted and clear-eyed
about
the risks and we're going to protect our
vital interests
and on hong kong i'm going to go to the
house of commons tomorrow to make a
further statement on
the work we've been doing with our
partners in government and i'll say more
about our response then
um but we're clear-eyed specifically
specifically some of your conservative
colleagues have written a letter
saying that they want you to suspend the
extradition treaty with
the country uh on because of what's been
happening of course with china
are you going to do that are you going
to do that well as i said on the 1st of
july when
i set out in the house of commons the
offer we're making to bno status
uh hong kong residents that with b o
status which is the status
dating back um to the the handover uh
we've made that offer
we've worked with our international
partners to to see what other
offers uh they will make to the people
of hong kong and i also said that we
would review a whole range of other
considerations one of the things that
we've reviewed is
our extradition arrangements and i will
be
updating the house on the conclusion of
that review along with other
uh things that we've been looking at
tomorrow and i think it's right for me
to do that tomorrow
um in the house of commons in the proper
way
okay it sounds a bit like we've got more
to hear from that very shortly in that
case
now um i just want to talk to you a bit
about coronavirus
at the beginning of the program we heard
from the head of the office of national
statistics who was speaking about
those concerns about the way public
health england had been
collecting data on the number of people
who died of covet 19
in england from saying uh that for
example
people who've recovered are still being
marked as dying of covert 19 and the
health secretary of course has uh
ordered this review
what i don't understand on this is that
you and other ministers for months
were standing in front of the uh
platform and downing street
giving us those numbers did you have no
idea how they were calculated because it
feels like a pretty dramatic oversight
no we've i think we've uh talked and i
think you've heard other people the
scientists talking about
the challenge with um for example uh not
so
so specifically in relation to deaths
but in relation to um
diagnosis that there is some under and
some over over-reporting in terms of
cases in the community and one of the
points and i think serene diamond who
you mentioned
also made this clear is that actually
whilst we do need to get those accurate
aggregate numbers
you can still rely on the data that
we've been publishing in relation to
the trend so if you take mid-april to
now we're mid-july
on the data we've seen the number of
daily deaths the average number of daily
deaths
go from over a thousand a day
heartbreaking just to think about that
to fewer than 100 a day on the average
weekly
aggregate or rolling data for the daily
deaths if you look at the number of
people in hospital
with covert 19 we've gone from over 20
000
to fewer than 200 and i do think i
understand the movement in the figures
and the importance to
to look at the trends but it just feels
like the government was caught unaware
by these issues in the way that the
deaths were calculated did you not know
how public health england were
calculating the figures
there's always been as i said there's
always been um
uh issues uh and methodological
questions
that we've been constantly trying to
streamline and correct if there were
issues with them um but
this was how they calculated them or not
this is clearly something new that's
arisen and as a result of that of course
the health sector has said we need an
urgent review so that we've got that
aggregate can't you've asked though this
is like you you were the ones reading
them out you have to take
ownership of them i mean shouldn't you
been trying to find out how they were
calculated
oh yes we did and we asked those
questions um and
there's a considerable amount of time
and effort on the rigor of the data we
were getting and of course
um as serene diamond has said we've also
had the ons
data um so you look you we've asked
those questions and
as they come to light when they come to
life and other countries are going
through similar challenges
with the methodology and there are
differences in the way that they can be
counted in the hospital
to the way they're counted uh in the
community and for example
uh the the on the on the uh
on the death certificate or in indeed
even if it's done by gps
where there has been some concern in
relation to cases let alone
deaths that there may be some in some
areas over
counting in other areas under accounting
so those issues those methodological
questions
have been we've constantly been trying
to make sure they're as
accurate as possible throughout this
process and as this has come to light
the health sector i think quite rightly
has ordered an urgent review so we've
got the aggregate view
we have also in fairness so if you said
from the outset that we would only have
a
a a a really reliable dependable sense
of the big picture in terms of the total
number right okay we have the
all-cause mortality uh which we only get
at the end
uh of the crisis and that would also in
terms of comparisons with other
countries
be what you'd need to rely on understood
and a couple of things just to
finish because we are running our time
mr rob now in an interview with the
sunday telegraph today the prime
minister
says another national lock gown was like
a nuclear deterrent he never wants to
use it
but patrick valence the chief scientific
advisor
has struck a slightly different note
saying come winter the challenges will
be very much greater
and there is a risk that this could also
need national measures
as well it feels a little bit like the
government and the scientific advisors
are out of step about whether a national
lock countdown should be necessary
well no i don't think that's right
sophie but national measures and
national lock
down aren't the same thing but we take
uh sir patrick violence one of our
finest public servants
uh advice very carefully and seriously
and we look at it right the way across
the board
um and ultimately politicians prime
minister myself and others
take responsibility but the key thing is
that the prime minister has been
emphasizing is the ability to take
locally
targeted measures and we've got new
powers for local authorities that are
going to be
put in place this week will enable us
to take targeted action to avoid
a national lockdown and and indeed
that is what is allowing us having that
power whether it's on the testing and
the tracing but also
the targeted local measures that we can
take and local authorities can take
also allows us to move forward and ease
restrictions as we've been doing
consistently but
only when the conditions are right when
we we know we've made the progress that
i just described
in getting the prevalence of this
disease down but also when we've got the
infrastructure the nhs infrastructure
the ventilator beds the testing and the
tracing
in the kind of shape which means that we
can be confident in getting life
back to something akin to normal okay
talking about getting
life back to normal uh just very finely
um syrian diamond also said that there
hadn't been an
uptick in infections that the ons has
noticed since the lockdown had started
to be eased
and the prime minister said on friday
that we hope by november at the earliest
we can continue to make
progress it may conceivably be possible
to move away from social distancing
measures
from the one meter rule so does this
mean that if infections continue to
fall social distancing could be over by
november
well if you look at the document that we
published this week about the next
phase of rebuilding we set out some
targets
and some measures that we're taking uh
on the first of august
then schools will come back on in
september and then towards uh october
and november there are other
areas where we would like to see if we
can make steps to getting back something
akin to normal but but i must stress
about this we've also said it and the
prime minister has been very clear on
this
it's all conditional on us making
continuing to make progress
with the data in the way i described the
number of people in hospital the number
of cases the number of deaths
making sure that we've got the
infrastructure in the nhs to
to to be able to cope particularly as we
approach winter so there's another 3
billion pounds of investment
going into the nhs to make sure that we
can in the round
be able to cope with any of the
pressures that we might have
both covered and non-covered and 19
health pressures
so and i think it is right though to
give businesses in the country that
sense of
a target and a sense of hope there'll be
some businesses that that will not be
able to go back to normal until right at
the end those final measures that we
take and i do think as they consider
whether you know they just got to lay
people off
or whether they're going to go into
administration they'll have taken on
debt they'll have
had the support from the government i do
think it is right that in the very
conditioned way and careful way
we have we give those businesses and
their employees
the hope that actually we can come
through this so we're doing it very
carefully as we've said
all along the conditions are there we're
monitoring it very carefully
but we do hope uh to be able to get back
closer to normal
and we'll take the careful steps the
short footed steps on the road map
towards that
uh eventual destination okay uh dominic
rob
foreign secretary thank you for being on
the program